[تصفيق]
زي ما انتم شايفين كده قاعده باسكال عادي
على ابلكيشن كل تنين تستخدموه تيك توك بس
اللي استغربته انا لقيت كميه فيديو
فظيعه بصراحه انا ما كنتش فاهمه هو ليه
الابلكيشن كله او معنا صح الميزه كلها
قلت يمكن الحاجات دي على بيستخدموها يعني
مثلا لو دخلت على جوجل قرات كنز اتفرجت
على
اجابه مختلفه صح
دخلت على جوجل
واتفرجت على بس في الاخر الاجابه كانت
واحده
كله
طب يمكن انا قلت انا دلوقتي متلخبطه مش
عارفه اعمل ايه الميزه كلها بتحط لنا
جدا لان
قررت ان انا هبص على البيزنس في حياتي
هاوسع على مامتي اللي هي شيزابيث في
وهبص على بابايا اللي هو
الموضوع ده بدل ما يحل اللغبط اللي عندي
ويفهمني انا عايزه اعمل ايه لخبطني اكتر
لان في الاخر الثوم
فليه الميديا كلها بتريموت فاضل واحده بس
طب يمكن المشكله فيا يمكن انا الوحيده
اللي شايفه كده
انا هعمل
دي هيكون فيها ايه من 13 ل 40 سنه
عشان يكون عندي
هسال الناس سؤال مهم جدا واللي هو
ما استغربتش لما لقيت ان اكتر من 40
ليه لان انا لما بسمع الكلمه دي اول حاجه
بتيجي في بالي هي
عشان انا مختاره شغلانتي او مثلا
عشان لو انا اشتغلت في حاجه وتعبت فيها
اسمي انا اللي معروف مش اسمي شركه وخلاص
وطبعا
ان انا فخوره باللي انا عملته
بس
الموضوع واشوف هو ايه اصلا ايه اللي بيحصل
لما تكوني لقيت ان اكتر من سكسي فايف فاول
كم سنه فازاي الفرس عاليه قوي كده
كل الناس دي كانت مختاره انشر
بعدها ابتديت ان انا ادور اكتر واشوف عامه
هي ايه
محتاجها او ايه الحاجات
لقيت ان هم هيتقسموا
[موسيقى]
اول فاكتور اللي هو
الحاجات اللي انا عملتها هقدر امرنها
اتحكم فيها حاجات اللي هي تحت السيطره
يعني
لو بصينا هتلاقينا بالفاكتز هنلاقي ان هي
زي السكنز سكنز كلنا عارفينها مثلا
حاجات كلنا عارفينها وكلنا عارفينها
بس بالنسبه لي الحته الجديده كانت
هتقسم كده برضو 2 مهمين اول بوينت اللي
التحمل النفسي بتاع كل شخص وتاني
هو اصلا
هيحتاج يستحمل ايه ده هو قلب
ففيه ايه وحش قوي يعني ممكن يواجهه
دي من اكبر المسكن
ليه لان
ممكن يقعد من سنتين لثلاث سنين مش بيجي له
اي
وبالنسبه لناس كثيره جدا ان هو يقعدوا
سنتين او تلاته بيدفعوا بس من غير اي
مقابل دي فكره محبطه جدا واصلا ممكن ناس
تسيب البيزنس بعد اول سنه
اما تاني حاجه بقى ان هو ممكن يقلب
يعني
ان هو
هيشتغل كتير قوي لدرجه ان هو هيجيبها كتير
في حياته زي مثلا
عن فاميلي والحاجات دي عامه
تاني حاجه
الحاجات اللي احنا ما نقدرش نتحكم فيها هي
الاكس او اشتركم الشخص عايش فيها
ازيكلود حاجتين مهمين اول حاجه هتكون
يعني مثلا لو واحد عنده 100,000 جنيه ما
عندوش اي فلوس تانيه متحوش ما ينفعش ان
الشخص ده يحط 100 الف جنيه كلها في
البيزنس لان في احتماليه ان البيزنس ده
يفشل ولو فشل هو الشخص هيواجه صعوبه كبيره
جدا ان هو ميك اب
تاني حاجه هتكون
الادله
يعني ان لو حصل حاجه في العالم غيرت طريقه
البيزنس في يوم وليله
هيقدر يكمل عادي جدا ولا اكن حاجه حصلت
تعالوا ناخد اكزامبل شركه كلنا عارفينها
ديزني ديزني بعد ما انتجت اول كرتون موفي
ابتدت تجوه انتم وده كان بسبب الحرب
العالميه
بسبب ان والديزني
السريع اللي حصل ابتدى ان هو
ودلوقتي ديزني من انجح الشركات اللي احنا
نعرفها
طب هو لو حد معندوش
ولا عنده
ده كده خلاص معناها ان هو فشل
لا
الشخص ده هيكون عنده 2 من سيناريوس
اول سيناريو ان هو لو مصمم جدا على
بس
هيسافر هي لستك اكسفاجتيشنز يعني هيكون
عارف ان نسبه النجاح بتاعته اقل من العادي
وده عشان لو فعلا حصل وفشل ما يحصلوش
احباط او
التاني هيكون ان هو
زي مثلا
او حتى
مهمه جدا واللي هي ان اللايف
كده كده
طب من كلامي ده
[تصفيق]